pues muy buenos días para que también
raúl ahora mismo están a punto lo que
parece de terminar estas reuniones aquí
en el palacio presidencial de dolmabahçe
en estambul al lado mismo del bósforo y
se espera que dentro de pocos minutos
salgan representantes de las dos
delegaciones ucraniana y rusa a hablar
un poco a la prensa de los avances que
parece que están habiendo teniendo lugar
aunque son muy tímidos según explican
varios reportes de la prensa rusia
estaría dispuesta a dejar de pedir a
ucrania que se des nacif y que según
dicen ellos mismos a cambio ucrania
renunciaría a formar parte de la
organización de la otan y tendría así
una neutralidad militar que eso no
significaría que no pudiese entrar
después a la unión europea y que ucrania
se garantizase unas garantías de
seguridad para sí misma en materia de
defensa militar a lo que ahí entraría a
turquía que podría ser uno de estos
países hay que garantizar esta seguridad
y ahora mismo aparte de eso turquía se
muestra muy dispuesta a mediar de hecho
turcos aseguran que les gustaría en un
futuro que los dos presidentes ruso y
ucraniano volodymyr selenski
a vladimir putin se encontrasen en esta
mula mediación de receta que de hecho ha
estado esta mañana al inicio de las
negociaciones hace algo más de 5 horas
ha reunido con las dos delegaciones que
no se han tocado en ningún momento por
las informaciones de ayer que explicaban
que podía haber agentes químicos hace un
mes que envenenaron a los ucranianos
adriana preguntó cuáles son los puntos
principales que defienden tanto rusia
como ucrania y además teniendo en cuenta
el pasado las rondas de negociaciones y
de diálogos fallidas hay realmente
posibilidades de un avance para que se
logre un alto el fuego
esa es probablemente la gran pregunta y
se la hacen también los miembros de la
delegación ucrania está pidiendo un alto
el fuego humanitario permanente que
sirva para sobre todo a salvar y aliviar
la ciudad marie paule completamente
exiliada sitiada desde hace más de dos
semanas rusa de aumento no se parece
estar dispuesta a ello si no se muestran
y si no se consiguen sus puntos que son
básicamente ahora mismo que ucrania
reconozca la soberanía rusa dentro de la
península de crimea anexionada por rusia
en 2014 además de las dos regiones en el
donbass de donets y lugar son dos
posiciones maximalistas son las que
están pidiendo rusia ahora miento que en
el momento que ucrania no parece muy
dispuesta a aceptar sí que ha dicho de
lenski en alguna ocasión que ucrania
podría estar dispuesta a reconocer algún
tipo de autonomía estas dos regiones del
donbass y crimea pero nunca cederían a
una presión rusa que es lo que pide
absolutamente que las regiones de crimea
y el donbass formen parte de la
federación rusa sobre todo crimea que
fue directamente anexionada que ahora
mismo es parte de la federación
a rusa las negociaciones espera que
duren hasta mañana de hecho así lo han
afirmado ambas partes sin embargo se
desconoce si pueden haber llegado a buen
puerto después de estas cinco horas y
por lo tanto no sabemos si realmente
continuarán o si no lo que sí se sabe es
que las negociaciones han pasado de
bielorrusia a estambul uno de los
motivos por los que comentábamos por el
envenenamiento de parte de la delegación
ucraniana entre la que también forma
parte no comentó en la delegación pero
si las asociaciones aquí en estambul el
oligarca roman abramovich que se ha
erigido el mismo con una especie de
mediador junto con los turcos para
intentar mandar mensajes directamente
desde putin hacia selenski y desde
selenski hacia putin